[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul and how do you make one
of the best superhero movies ever made
even better
it's simple you break down all the ins
and outs of the movie to show
150 insane details in easter eggs that
nolan left in his dark knight trilogy
now like all films in the set the dark
knight opens with the bat symbol
surrounded by something that will hold
significant meaning in the movie
in begins it was bats which represented
fear in rises it's
ice breaking to show bane and in the
dark knight we see it flying through
fire
fire is a wild and chaotic thing whereas
the bat symbol is very steady in its
shape
this shows the battle between batman and
the joker who both represent
both order and chaos in the movie alfred
states that
some men just want to watch the world
burn and joker even uses fire at several
points in the film
rachel is killed with it harvey is
burned and the hospital is blown up in a
massive explosion
the film is very much laced with the
idea of duality as
not only is there of course batman and
the joker but harvey dent ends up
becoming two-face
however it extends far beyond this and
can be seen in lots of aspects of the
film
joker takes two hostages in both harvey
and rachel
he kills two people called harvey and
dent he makes two boats have a standoff
and in the final battle has the hostages
swap clothes with his men
joker also wants half of the gangster's
money and hopefully i've shown you that
there's always two sides to every coin
no i'm not talking about harvey dense
lucky one but you know i like doing crap
jokes whenever i can
now after this opening shot we cut to a
long one over the gotham skyline
in which a window is suddenly broken and
the joker's gang swooped down
this imagery very much carries the idea
that peace in gotham has been shattered
and the clowns are descending upon the
city cut to the joker and if you look in
the distance you can actually see a
spider-man 3 movie poster
making this film the epic marvel and dc
collabo
that we've all been waiting for we hear
the joker goons talk about a 5-way
split which is then corrected to 6. this
shows that the joker told each and every
one of them something different and hid
the bus driver
because it's all part of his plan
throughout the movie he says do i really
look like a guy with a plan
and now no he doesn't yeah the genius of
the joker is that he's always one step
ahead of everyone else
after gamble interrupts his speech with
the mobsters he starts reciting the
outline of what he plans to do
later in the movie when talking to the
boats we can see him reading off a piece
of paper
showing that he does indeed pre-plan
what he's going to say and do
during the mobster meeting he points at
the television and says he hates
schemers
but he himself is one and he just wants
to seem like a wild dog
because well that's all part of his plan
now the mask that the joker wears during
the heist is actually calling back to
the 1966 batman tv show
in which the joker donned it in an
episode called the joker is world
the entire strategy that the joker uses
here which is to make the robbers take
out one another
plays on his understanding that humans
are self-centered and selfish
each one of them will kill the others so
that they can get something better
and this model is very much used for the
boats at the end
though he's unable to correctly guess
the outcome there joker throws the
entire team under the bus literally and
unmasks saying the famous line
stranger this is of course a play on the
term whatever doesn't kill you makes you
stronger
and throughout the movie joker does
twist and turn certain sayings
there is of course the changing of the
van to read slaughter is the best
medicine
and let's put a smile on that face
something which refers to giving a
person a glasgow smile
rather than cheering them up like
hopefully this video is doing for you
now joker of course received this
glasgow smile himself
and unlike all those that have come
before this joker actually applied the
white paint himself
typically in the comics his skin is
bleached but throughout the movie if you
look closely at his hands
you will see that there is white paint
on his fingertips
leger actually put the makeup on himself
rather than using the onset team
as he wanted to have an organic feel to
the character rather than him being
someone who was simply pruned for a
movie
joker escapes into the bus after putting
a gas grenade in the bank manager's
mouth
and we can see that the string from its
pin is tied to the bottom of his jacket
this means that when he drives off it
will unhook and we later see something
similar when he goes to the gangsters
and has a lot of explosives in his coat
we then go to jim gordon standing beside
the bat signal
and since begins this has become a
staple of the gcpd
at the end of the dark knight rises one
of the most iconic shots is him standing
beside a repaired signal
which echoes this moment that appears
throughout the trilogy he's greeted by
ramirez who i think is based loosely on
detective montoya from the comics
however the latter is a good guy whereas
ramirez is a crooked cop
she mentions her mother being checked
into the hospital and this of course
becomes leveraged later on when joker
threatens to blow one up
she is indebted to the gang because of
her mother's medical bills
and it does ask the question would you
turn to crime to save your family
cut to batman carrying out a drug burst
on the scarecrow
and we're introduced to the batman
copycats which are based on the sons of
batman from the dark knight returns
batman is attacked by dogs and dogs
actually pop up quite a lot in the film
now when upgrading his armor bruce asks
how it'll hold up against them
which references this moment joker is
referred to as a mad dog
and joker later says to the chechen that
when a dog goes hungry
that he'll find out how loyal they
really are now the joker attacks batman
with dogs at the end of the movie
and it could be because he found out
from a secondhand source that he was
vulnerable to them
because of this opening drug bust batman
goes to gordon who's in a bank vault
and the character holds up a picture of
the joker on it we can see the numbers
2008
0 7 18 and if you reverse these you'll
get the 18th of july 2008
which is the day that the movie was
released in cinemas next we go to
batman's temporary batcave
in which we can see him stitching up his
arm this scar would actually later
appear on the dark knight rises
when we see the character in the cave
bruce is keeping an eye on both rachel
and harvey
and we see a fake out court scene with
the two in the comics it was during a
trial that harvey had acid thrown at him
by gangster moroni
and he became two-face however here he's
almost shot
showing a slight misdirect now the gun
doesn't go off
and then says you want to kill a public
servant mr maroney i recommend you buy
american
later in the movie the first person then
kills is public servant detective wurtz
who murders with a smith and weston aka
an american handgun
now it is possible that this gun came
from mr lao as we learned that they are
both chinese
before you call me a racist yeah moroni
was working with mr lao
so it doesn't make sense that he could
get him black market weaponry
now moroni himself in the long halloween
was a sort of rival to falcone
who in the last movie was taken down by
batman though the pair have worked
together as well
i do like that he's an excellent
succession in the film's canon
we see gordon and den meeting and
there's a lot of duality in this scene
both know that the other one has a
darker side to them and that they have
to work with what they're given
gordon refers to him as the white knight
which too brings up the idea of
opposites in the title the dark knight
this idea of mirroring is of course
shown in two-face but also in that
harvey works in the light to achieve
justice
whereas batman has to stick to the
shadows later on a piece of paper is
held up over harvey's face to make him
look like batman
but this being white hammers home the
idea of him being a white knight
bit of a reach harvey hints that he's
well aware that he's labeled two-faced
by gordon's colleagues
and this motif is even carried across to
his double-sided coin
which has two faces on it the idea
there's no way to really win with it
either
shows how manipulative that he can be
and how he presents things in a certain
way whilst hiding the truth
at the end of the movie gordon gives a
speech about the fallen white knight in
front of a giant picture of him
and if you look very closely this is
crooked
showing that the character himself was
two we see bruce asking
lucius for some upgrades and he makes a
joke about being able to turn his head
pretty much all the batman movies before
and since this have seen a cow with a
solid neck
so this is a sort of meta joke about
costume design in general
we're also introduced to coleman reece
who i think might actually be the dark
knights version of the riddler
similar to the riddler in the comics
rhys figures out who batman is
but he doesn't tell anyone because a
riddle that everyone knows the answer to
isn't worth saying reese's name itself
could be a play on the way that the
riddler
aka edward enigma is often called
mystery
or mystery enigma mysteries mystery
okay might be reaching there but you
know what i don't think i am
i jump to bruce taking out the prima
ballerina for some prima pizza
and the conversation moves on to how
batman in some ways is like a roman
protector
in begins raz al-ghul ii brought up rome
and how corruption caused the league of
shadows to bring down the empire
this hints once more at the idea of
duality as rome could be seen as good or
bad depending on who you ask
and it's a nice recurring motif across
these movies
harvey says either die a hero or you
live
long enough to see yourself become the
villain though this could be referring
to his journey in the movie
i've always taken it as batman's because
he in the end allows people to see him
as the bad guy
the joker goes and has his meeting with
the mob in which he does the
disappearing pencil trick
this was actually shot over two days and
it had 22 takes in total
nolan being nolan wanted to do the stunt
for real and this led to three knockouts
over the course of filming it
in the end the stuntman swiped the
pencil away at the last second leading
to what
is a completely unforgettable scene and
the funny thing about this scene
is that when the joker says something
serious the mobsters laugh
but when he's telling jokes they don't
this is seen in pretty much
all the lines of dialogue that he has
and it shows that he's not really a
clown
even though people find him funny we
join batman
harvey and gordon on the roof and this
scene massively echoes the long
halloween
in which they meet in a similar scene
they realize that they need lao and as
batman is the only one who doesn't have
a jurisdiction that he's the man for the
job
bruce enlists the help of lucius who
wants to use something known as skyhook
which is a real technique developed by
the cia in order to quickly get troops
out from behind
enemy lines lucius also gives batman his
new armor
and we see how the gauntlets fire off
which is something that he uses to help
defeat the joker with later on
throughout these movies there's lip
service paid to the armor being weak on
the sides
antalya later would exploit this in the
dark knight rises when she stabs bruce
in his weak points
after a hit is put out on his head the
joker fakes his own death to be taken to
gamble
he tells a story about how he got the
scores and this alters throughout the
movie which is actually a callback to
the killing joke
in that the joker said if he had a past
he'd prefer it to be multiple choice
and the chaotic nature of his backstory
shows just how much of an unreliable
narrator that he is
joker gets gamble's sidekicks to fight
each other to the death to be in his
gang
and this idea of getting people to turn
one another was of course used in the
bank heist
and later used on the boats batman goes
to china with lucius
and we see how sonar is used on a phone
to scan the building
later on we learned bruce actually
transformed all of gotham cell phones
into a sonar across the city
in order to track down the joker lucius
at one point actually questions why he's
dumping money into mobiles
and he says he's playing it very close
to the best this signifies that this was
his plan the whole time and it feels
very akin to the real-life patriot act
now this movie is sort of reactionary to
the fallout of 911
and much in the same way that the u.s
government was accused of spying on its
own people in order to catch terrorists
bruce does the same thing the film
really makes you question whether an
authoritarian figure
should be able to hack into people's
privacy to catch the bad guys
and it's a very deep subject matter to
cover in a superhero film
now if you're enjoying the video i'd
massively appreciate it if you showed us
that this was the breakdown you deserved
by hitting the thumbs up button if you
subscribe that'll massively put a smile
on my face
and also mean that you never miss one of
our easter egg hunts on a film
anyway bruce bursts into laos building
and the solid backpack thing that we see
the cape folded up into
is actually something that nolan wanted
to adopt for the bat pod
he was worried that the cape would get
caught in the back wheel and yank the
rider's head off
and though that wasn't the case it's
nice that the idea of it makes it across
here
when bruce shoots bombs against the
windows we can also see a countdown
timer of roughly 2 minutes and 30
seconds
and this is actually how long the scene
lasts before they explode
showing how well nolan likes to edit
things to ticking clock
not long after we go to the mayor's
office and see that the joke has started
killing some of the copycats
he leaves a card on one saying will the
real batman please stand up
i think this might be a reference to
eminem and all the people that copied
him
turns out that this is actually the
batman dude who has bruce at the start
what makes him any different and he's
been killed and forever recorded on
handheld video
now this video was actually made by
heath ledger himself and it accounts the
victim's death
these sort of homemade hostage films
became prevalent with the release of
handheld digital cameras
and of course cell phones which pits
this movie even closer to reality
now at bruce's penthouse there is a
party being held
and i wasn't invited which i'm
completely furious over
alfred and harvey meet for the first
time and the former says that he hasn't
known rachel for her whole life just yet
which could be the scriptwriters playing
up the fact that
he will actually know her because yeah
she dies
bruce enters asking where is harvey and
later on when the joker arrives at the
party he does the exact same thing
this shows that the two are closer than
you think and there's another moment
that highlights their similarities
when bruce walks out onto the balcony he
tosses away the champagne
and when joker comes in he grabs a glass
and spills the contents everywhere
this shows that both like to keep a
clear head and that they only make it
seem like they drink to keep up
appearances
bruce brings up harvey's campaign slogan
i believe in harvey then
which is actually a line from the end of
the long halloween when yoga enters the
party you can see
michael kane looking very shocked and he
was actually meant to say something at
this point
but he was so enamored by the
performance that he completely forgot
his line
amongst the party guests namely the old
man that joker grabs
is none other than senator patrick leahy
who's a huge batman fan
he's actually appeared in a number of
batman movies and was blown up in the
senate during bbs
joker lets rachel fall out of a window
and batman has to dive out after her
which apparently lets the joker know
that the pair care about one another but
meh
i don't know i feel like he would have
done that for anyone anyway
occur to alfred and bruce talking about
what he wants and alfred tells the story
about how some men just want to watch
the world burn
bruce says that criminals aren't
complicated and this is a call back to
razar ghoul who said the same thing to
him in batman begins
i absolutely love the way that bruce is
trying to scan joker's face in order to
find a file for him
but non-exist we never get a true
backstory for the character in this
movie
and his anonymity is one of his greatest
weapons
batman digs a bullet out of a wall in
order to find a fingerprint on it
and i believe that the bullet wall
antenna was referencing the scene
due to the colour of the wall it's a
reach yet it's a reach now cut to the
funeral
and the joker makes it seem like he's
going to be sniping the official
because that's what tends to happen in
assassinations
however he's always misdirecting people
and he actually goes in with his men
disguised as gods
because they'll be able to carry guns he
knows that batman will find him
and lures him to a location in the hopes
that he can be taken out by his sniper
and though it doesn't go according to
plan it still shows his ingenuity
army captures a guard played by david
das malchain who's been cast in a number
of comic book properties including
gotham
ant-man and the upcoming suicide squad
movie
harvey holds him at gunpoint and we can
see that one side of his face
is almost completely in shadow
foreshadowing his turn to the dark side
hey have a nut
a batman talks him down and in hindsight
we know that because of his coin that he
never would have killed him
but it still shows that harvey is
willing to mentally torture someone
he holds a press conference and we hear
the line from a heckler
things are worse than ever which is a
callback to when rachel said the same
thing and batman begins
now gordon's death is fake showing that
just like batman
he has to operate outside of
jurisdiction and so on in order to catch
this new kind of criminal
the car chase takes place and the bat
pod bursts out the batmobile
in the run-up to the film it was said by
nolan that the bat pod was actually in
batman begins
he just had to look very closely and
this is of course
where it was all along your cheeky boy
nolan i kind of see this scene as being
similar to the one in batman returns in
which the batmobile is destroyed
but the dark knight is still able to go
on due to the pod coming out of it
batman and the joker face down on the
road which foreshadows the idea of them
being an unstoppable force
hitting an immovable object harvey is
seemingly saved but he's escorted by
detective wurtz and ramirez
and as we later learn they are working
for the mob joker is placed in a cell
and i love how amongst his knives
there's also a potato peeler
you never know when you're gonna want to
make some chips one of his henchmen is
brought in
and we learned that he has a cell phone
bomb placed inside of him
similar to batman the joker has
weaponized cell phones in a way to
further his own gains
which is a great little mirroring
between the two batman and joker have a
conversation with each other
and joker even hints at the police will
hump batman down
which is of course how the movie ends
the joker says you complete me
and this moment is a call back to jerry
maguire something that lego batman
watches
in his solo movie bringing the two
franchises together
joker discusses interrogation tactics
such as not going for the head
which likely shows that he was involved
in some sort of torture
later in the movie joker talks about how
things are all part of the plan
even if they're horrible and mentions a
group of soldiers being blown up
which many have theorized confirms that
he is in fact an iraq war vet
if this is true then he could have been
a military interrogator that was
attacked by insurgents
and the scars that we see on his face
could actually have come from a bomb
now in this scene the joker makes batman
choose between harvey and rachel
and he says that he's gonna have to
choose who lives and who dies
it's revealed that the joker actually
gives batman the opposite locations
but in some ways he was telling the
truth joker said that he will have to
choose who dies
and batman chooses to go to rachel who
is revealed to be harvey
therefore in choosing rachel he's
actually choosing her to die
and yeah it's it's very smart once you
really think about it
now he reveals that den is being held at
250
52nd street saying that again as 250
52nd street there's this idea of there
being two
twos in it and 50 50 which foreshadows
him becoming two face
joker actually allows batman to beat the
crap out of him
and we can see later that he uses a
shattered piece of glass from the mirror
to take a policeman hostage when he's
sitting against the crack mirror we can
actually see those shards behind him
and therefore piece together how he was
able to get out
now the shots of rachel and harvey
actually foreshadow their fate
rachel is pretty much in complete
darkness whereas half of harvey's face
is lit
hinting to us what's gonna happen next
joker escapes
and they honestly could have stopped the
movie there i think it still would have
been one of the best films ever made
alfred almost gives bruce a letter from
rachel and in the dark knight we hear
more about this
bringing the moment full circle in the
hospital harvey lifts up his coin
and sees that the other half of it is
burned and that's because
his other half got burned a sorry rachel
now it is scott on one side and not the
other which is
lucky as he can now use that cool little
character gimmick that that he's been
wanting to do for so long
the joker holds all the hospitals
hostage and puts out a hit on mr reese
meaning that batman has to go and save
him as mentioned in our begins breakdown
this car is actually a lamborghini mochi
lago
which means bat in spanish nice little
character gimmick there too
now the joker reference is burning half
the money which could also be a nod to
how he burned half of harvey
joker has the hospitals cleared out so
that he can swoop in and take him
without any guards
i always found it hilarious how it was
only after he took the mask off
that harvey realized who he was wasn't
the bright wig and the stupid face paint
that gave it away was
it was the mouth when he allows harvey
to hold his life in his hand
he actually holds back the hammer on the
gun showing that
even if he lost the flip he wouldn't
lose and would get out of the situation
without dying
joker blows up the hospital and contrary
to popular belief
this wasn't just one take and made up
there and then
heath practised it over and over again
to get everything down
so that when the explosion did go off
the performance looked amazing
the joker records another hostage video
with the gnn news correspondent
and we can see that he's hung upside
down almost like a bat
batman enacts his final plan with help
from lucius and
harvey goes out on a quest for revenge
when moroni is just about to get in the
car if you slow the footage down
you can actually see that harvey grabs
his henchman and pulls him out the way
explaining how the switcheroo was
carried out harvey also takes off his
seat belt when he's in it
just before it flips showing how he
manages to get out
batman storms joker's hideout and we can
see the sonar which looks very similar
to his detective vision
so far joker has been right about human
nature
but i love how in this one we prove him
wrong and humanity wins the fight
for gotham's soul batman manages to
catch the joker
and saves his life showing that he is
the true hero that will do good no
matter what
he talks to him upside down showing that
the pair have opposing ideologies
and it's one of the most haunting ways
to save their world to the character
now the beauty of joker's plan here is
that he wanted to show batman that the
police would turn on him
and in taking down the swat team they
eventually do
batman goes to harvey and saves gordon's
son
by diving over the edge with the villain
bruce's fall and later limps explains
why he's got one in the dark knight
rises
and it's likely that only his cape
catching the air is what stopped him
from dying
gordon says thank you and batman says
you don't have to say that
which is of course playing on the ending
of batman begins in which the cape
crusader
said something similar batman takes the
fall for harvey
and he lives long enough to see himself
become the villain the hero that gotham
deserves but not the one it needs
harvey is someone who represents what
the people can aspire to
whereas if people try and become batman
they'll end up like the sons
and will break the law rather than
upholding it for now batman knows that
he must sacrifice his image in order to
serve the greater good
and hopes that people will aspire to be
more akin to harvey than him
making him the true hero of it all that
ends the movie and i really hope you
enjoyed it as a lot of work went into
this
and again i'd massively appreciate the
thumbs up if you enjoyed this video
then make sure you check out our full
brighton batman begins which will be
linked on screen right now
without the way thank you for watching
until the end i've been paul
you've been the best and i'll see you
next time take care
peace